so we we started out once again with
nonco stuff and this time we worked with
a partner than lovely
assistant the assistant um started out
imagining an imaginary wall in between
us this is like one of the walls of our
imaginary hallway this is an exercise to
help keep clean planes while spinning we
started out on the horizon with our arms
on that horizontal Focus point and we
just played with same time same
direction just rolling our hands all the
way around you gentle contact with your
partner and you want to allow your hands
to roll all the way around to the backs
of the
hands and the
Palms so that way your fingers can
always always always point in the right
direction and as you get comfortable
with this you can start to play with
turning the Torso back and
forth to help smooth out this movement
and make it less work for the
arms then we course both both ways then
we did
Opposites which is a little trickier ta
Chi
arms the focus points once again are
those
horizontal points kind of at shoulder
height where we're both reaching out to
the side there but there's also
important secondary Focus points right
up here at the top where we want to make
sure we're on our second our Center
Line to keep this flowing nicely and as
you get comfortable with this you can
really allow the Turning of the Torso to
help move to the center line and
eventually the other side scissor so we
played with that we played with doing
that by ourselves as
well and like if you want something to
kind of keep track of your focus points
while you're doing this we were doing
get lined up on your Center Line you can
snap on the center line one down clap on
the horizon snap on the center line Clap
Snap Clap Snap Clap
Snap we eventually played
with uh turning this so that that super
important horizontal meeting point is
also that's the point where you're
turning through stepping around your
arms become parallel for that as your
arms are coming towards the horizon
there to become parallel that's when you
step over to the other side so that your
circleing on the other wall so now I'm
circling on this
wall and as I come to the side that's
where I step to turn the other
wall now it will feel like your arms
switch directions because in terms of
how they're rotating in your shoulder
sockets they do but if you notice like
my right arm is always fall falling down
the window falling down the window even
when I turn that's still the case and
that can help keep you acclimated and
make sure you didn't accidentally switch
into something else on accident as you
turn and so we eventually we even faced
down the hallway where it's kind of
impossible to keep your arms your arms
can't really keep going so
good unless you turn from side to side
so what we did was once again like maybe
the right arm is going down in front the
left arms going up one way you can do it
they keep going that direction you turn
to the side go up the back all the way
down in front again you go to the other
side that way and no matter what you do
it's always going to come back for the
same position where one the same hand is
going down the same hand is going up so
you follow your little like hand rocket
ships
around which really this this helps you
to do continuous
turns
we had to to cover uh some walking and
turning real quick basically whenever
you make a half turn that's essentially
the equivalent of half turn forward half
turn forward is the equivalent of
stepping half turn backward half turn
backward If It Go stepping backward but
when you alternate front side turn back
side turn you're pivoting around while
moving in a straight
line and we put it all together really
awesome you guys pick
f with our split time opposite arms
focusing on our Focus points on the
horizon spotting as we step spotting the
other wall as we step away from it spot
where I'm going spot where I'm going
away from towards away towards away
towards away so on and so far getting
busy spinning around the other way so as
to
un uny yourself so same thing with your
poy if you're spending your split time
butterfly here and you want to turn with
it as your PO scissored right
there you can step around into a
reverse or other ways PL butterfli a
reverse spinning out
way and you know you can play with this
long
arm eventually if you start playing with
flower
patterns this applies and notice how
making my little pedals at those four
cardinal directions we also played with
just swinging the boy right small
pendulum really kind of trying to get
your pendulum up to the
Horizon stops at the Horizon falls back
down doing that long arm feeling how
your torso can turn to allow your arm to
more smoothly pendulum with your boy as
per
usual to work on C your planes if you
swing or spin close to a
wall now I have this situation where I
obviously can't get too close to the
wall so my my body is just
subconsciously working
on straight planes and of course I can't
hit my leg so very naturally you're just
going to keep fitting it right in there
on a straight plane next to the wall
this will help you C Up Your Flames
really nicely we also played with
starting to make kind of pendulum Circle
throwing the pendulum where our arms
kind of circling around we can draw
essentially something like a circle with
the p head but you're not actually
spinning the poy it's just kind of like
you're rowing a
boat continuing to work on nice plain
control while swinging
pendulums we did some long arm versions
We got the long arm going
and that once you get to the horizon
drag it across back
down and then we started playing with
the breaking your brain and
half always fun right you spin you spin
both of your boy and then you got to be
able to separate your brain enough to
tell one to keep going and one to stop
so that it can go in a pendulum and the
opposite
dire in the opposite
direction
first you can kind of front stall and go
into pendulum but eventually you want to
be able to smoothly
transition right into a
pendulum and you want to be able to
smoothly transition from pendulum
back into spinning both of them it feels
a bit like you know bringing the the
foot off the gas put in the clutch sort
of a thing where one thing is slowing
down one thing speeding up it's that
it's kind of like that sort of feeling
and once you get it it's it's really
useful and you have it and it's easy but
at first it's going to be EV head sort
of challenge one of the one of the
things that you may want to eventually
be able to do is
switch there this was the home play you
said right this is yeah for home play
see if you can maybe even work your way
up to
eventually able to every time with a
weave you see how she just initiated
that she had to swing for a forward
weave under my POI
first and then come back so whoever
initiates has like a little extra job
they do like a little intro but if
you're spinning
backwards yeah okay I'll throw that in
there let's go in reverse if you're
spinning backwards it's upside down so
that means if I want to initiate I go
over the top to initiate
so and this in general backwards tends
to equal up and forwards tends to equal
down or
under and before we did the three beat
we we did the two beat songs so a two
beat is just I'll initiate by going
under and then come back and we'll do
that over and over
again does like that and if you get used
to if you get used to either one person
plays in your Shader for the while then
the person plays initiator for the while
then you're both you're both good at
initiating and you can do a two beat
with either hand on top